two o'clock I will open the subcommittee
I'm going to call this a work session on
House Bill 421
and
at this time we will recognize the
sponsor of this bill representative Reed
you wanna
so so basically our recap of this is
um we heard some testimony
and from you know from that the bill was
written pretty short and sweet
but as we went through the testimony we
kind of went down a rabbit hole
and now we are kind of here to address
that to see if we can get the
legislation written so that everything
that we heard in testimony will be put
into this
and
so I believe that's where we're probably
the best place to pick it up from thank
you madam chair
um so the the main two issues that were
brought up I believe all of the
testimony was in favor of the bill and
certainly all the comments from the
committee was in favor of the premise of
the bill the two issues that got brought
up is a little bit of
um ambiguity around the type of product
and some of the kind of more new age
products could like divacup could
propose a security risk so we wanted to
allow incarcerated people to choose the
product that they wanted that suited
their needs but still be able to allow
for that security the language and this
language was vetted and approved by
um the actually I think the commissioner
herself suggested this language and it's
the same for state and County
um and I'll just start reading the
superintendent of each County
Correctional Facility it's also says it
for the state shall provide menstrual
hygiene products to all people who
menstruate in the custody of the county
and adequate amounts as necessary at no
cost to such person the incarcerated
person shall be provided a choice of
feminine hygiene products to include at
a minimum pads tampons and panty liners
of varying strengths necessary for their
menstrual needs the number and type of
menstrual hygiene products kept in
incarcerated person cell shall not be
excessive so as to create a safety or
security issue and shall be used only
for the intended purpose
in this section menstrual hygiene
product and it defines what that means
it's any product designed to address
menstruation excuse me representative is
that an amendment that you have yes and
I sent it to you but I was just emailing
to the rest of the subcommittee members
when you called me up so
um and then the other issue that let me
see if I can get that printed for us oh
absolutely if do we have a yeah Brad if
I forward that to you are you able to
print that for us
it's zero one three three h
please hold yes
I think this might make it easier for
all if we can read it let it happen you
have to sit there and read it and I I
will say that the other issue that was
brought up was the idea because we had
numerous people testifying that there
had been examples of people who had
gotten infections specifically from
panties that were provided to them the
state does always provide new pansies
but the counties do not so uh what we
did to address that again had the
Commissioners okay
was let me just find it
any items provided by the county to
incarcerated persons that are impacted
by menstruation shall be provided in an
adequate number and and this is
sanitized but it was proposed to say new
shall be provided new
um so I might be looking at the actual
wrong version of the amendment but I can
certainly get that fixed
before being provided to another
incarcerated person is what it said
all right so that was that was sent to
Brad and he's going to hook us up with
our actual paper copies of that
um so those were the two issues that
were brought up and as far as I know all
the stakeholders including the county I
mean excuse me the State Department of
Corrections commissioner uh Haynes
um are all in support of these
particular uh Corrections
okay so thank you representative so
I'm trying to keep this very very
informal so we can you know all be
together here would you ladies like to
are you guys okay if we just have like a
conversation
okay so one of the questions that I that
I have that I just want to make sure is
so wear it on the amendment that she
just read which again is coming into us
where it said about the supplies being
kept kept with the person
and it said you know however much was
supposed to be there I is is there
wording there that we have to put
for you guys so and I guess my my exact
question is what is
is it a discretionary where it says the
amount like who decides what is
excessive or not
um
pastor
and then um
so if if I may so uh the reason
at a time the goal of course is to make
short
yeah the goal of course is to make sure
that the incarcerated may I have one of
those
make sure that the incarcerated person's
menstrual needs are met and their
sanitation needs are met so we didn't
want to give an exact number I
understand there's a Senate bill that
does raise what the practice is on the
state level which is 15 as was cited and
raises that to a mandatory 20 at minimum
I did not feel that giving a specific
number was advisable because if the
incarcerated person actually doesn't
need 20 that kind of becomes an unfunded
mandate uh which I understand there was
some question around that but since
there is as I said in Committee in the
hearing since there is already
understood to be a constitutional
requirement to take care of the basic
health and sanitation needs of
all-incarcerated persons I don't believe
that specifying that that includes
menstruation needs goes beyond what's
already required of the state and of
counties that we're simply clarifying
that actually this is part of that basic
need need but if you were to say 20 and
someone didn't need 20 then that would
be problematic so
the re
I want to I I feel like I need to make a
disclosure here
disclaimer
last year
I was on committee with some people that
could
pick a bone dry
and I'm trying to foresee that sure
so do you think in your opinion and and
are our fellow friends here do we have
to say specifically so where you have
you know okay of their choice we have
that in there right
um do we need to have the wording not
necessarily A A brand
and just the actual type I'm I'm fine to
include that
okay
okay so let's see where we would let's
see where we would put that because we
can just write it right now so
line 15. okay so the incarcerated person
shall be provided at a choice of a
choice of feminine hygiene products to
include at a minimum pads tampons and
panty lighters a varying strengths
necessary for the menstrual needs so
after that is that where we would put
not necessarily named brand I don't know
exactly how to word that it could be
yeah you do you guys want to come up
here we're okay with that request
yes
we do have to actually have that in
there yeah it's crazy wherever wherever
you're wherever you're comfortable
sitting where I mean we're all just
working on this right
or you might just put standard issue
before the word pads tampons and Penny
liners
okay so if we could put it
shall be provided so on line 14
so it says in car incarcerated person
shop he provided so we're thinking right
there a choice of standard issue a
choice of standard issue feminine
hygiene products starts after a choice
of and it's going to be the word
standard issue
oh thank you so much
oh that'll be very helpful if I end up
being the one to go have this done do
you did you see what we're putting that
I do so Shelby provided a choice of
standard issue feminine hygiene products
to include
okay
so on line 20 where it says sanitized is
where it was suggested that the counties
May argue that what they're providing is
already sanitized and that the word new
since that is what the state does would
be preferable
yeah what line is that on line 20.
of the amended Amendment the amendment
okay in fact it shall be provided an
adequate number of sanitized would that
include sheets yeah so
the count the state may not provide new
sheets currently and I did send that
email to the county commissioner and had
not heard back specifically on that
issue she and she did approve this
language but I specifically went back
and said are you okay specifically with
this line so I haven't heard back on
that yet but she already saw it
so our sheets are like assigned per
person so when laundry's done it's put
everything's labeled with people's names
and things like that if they if it has
blood or anything like that it's
disposed of with car with our current
practice but we also do have a policy
that kind of outlines what happens if
there's any kind of Bio contamination
and how that laundry is kept separate
and done differently and I can provide
that too if that's if yeah if we can
maybe draw for from the policies that
this wouldn't want to put the whole
possible no but like some some basic
summation of that I would think would be
suitable for putting into RSA regarding
the counties basically we understand
that the state already does a good job
at this and that the complaints that
we've gotten have been exclusively from
County facilities so I think lifting up
the County requirements to the level of
State
okay all right so one of the things that
that I believe that this is a dressing
right here which is line 20 but
this still doesn't say
necessarily new it just says shall be
provided in an adequate number and
sanitized before being provided to
another incarcerated person right so we
stole back to the you may get somebody
else's route I'm so sorry that you're in
here so I I actually think when I just
read the when this got printed I read
the wrong amendment number because I had
an amendment it was suggested to change
that to new and I had an amendment
drafted so I think we're working
specifically to to deal with changing
sanitize to new so but it's fine we can
work with this uh and then just change
it again
what what oh thanks Ellen
um so is that the new language was
already approved by the uh commissioner
Hanks I believe so but it only apply if
you notice it was only put into the
County Section and I wrote to her and
said this line the specific line that
we're discussing was only added to the
County Section are you okay with it with
the state and that's what I haven't
heard back on I just have a question I'm
just I mean as a nurse I've worked in
hospitals and blood is a you know I mean
obviously it's a pathogen but
um laundry services don't even though
laundry is Blood Stained maybe it is
sanitized with the intent to remove it
when it's not removable then it's
discarded I'm just a little worried
about when we say new everything that
it's going to be problematic okay in the
big I think the Senate you know but the
question is what does sanitize mean does
it mean
stained and or you know so that's I
don't know I'm just being well we
started like they're trying to tell us
so let's see what they want to say thank
you and just for members of the
committee my name is Kate Horgan I
represent the association of counties
um superintendent Henry apologizes he
can't be here because the opioid
committee is meeting at the same time
and he also sits on that so uh I did
just send him this amendment
um he is fine with all of the changes
that have just been discussed as he just
texted me and said yes that's fine
um so the counties have no problem with
this there we do have new
superintendents so all 10 counties
currently have a policy that products
are provided to female inmates similar
to the state it's a standard issue you
may not get the particular brand you
want but tampons pants panty liners are
all offered so so the only question that
I think that we're still all having is
if we put new does that mean that that
every you know superintendent Henry I
just gave him that change and he said
he's fine that makes sense to him
okay
excellent
um I I guess my question is
I can foresee the challenge being if
we're talking about both new
undergarments as well as new sheets new
bed linens and so I don't know if we
need rather than any item that might be
impacted by menstruation being new if
any
undergarments being new I mean I don't
know the idea of someone being and I
know that you said it doesn't happen at
the state level but the idea of any
person being issued anyone else's
panties recycled Underpants is
it's cruel and inhumane and and there's
no way that that can be
I think that's what we're working on
yeah and we and we heard of at least two
people who had developed um infections
from yeah so I'm just wondering if
rather than leaving it as as broad as
any product if it needs to split it out
if we need to split that out so that
the understanding is under I mean I can
see sheets being okay properly sanitized
and recycled so underline 19
so where it says any items maybe instead
of any items provided maybe that should
say any undergarments provided by the
county incarceration first that are
impacted by menstruation shall be what
about close would you put new
clothing could be impacted as well
but I don't so I don't necessarily think
a pair of jeans has the same impact
being if those right you know if those
were if those were used versus
undergarments so what if we say
undergarments for new and then sanitized
for any other product
I I actually like I like I mean I I wear
someone so you gave me a pair of jeans
I'd wear them yeah
okay I just have another suggestion
um just with the new thing I I
think we could achieve the same thing
without requiring that every time
somebody has you know a need for this
everything's new if we add just the
issue is the sanitized not necessarily
being sufficient so what if it says the
line 19 as it is and not in line 20
shall be provided in an
unstained adequate number oh an adequate
number comma unstained and sanitized
before that way if there's any stain on
it it's automatically rejected and if
they have to buy new they have to buy
new
but that's really the issue so is that
the undergarments so I I personally feel
the undergarments should be new do you I
every time for every person I don't
think that absolutely I don't think that
you can that's yeah I don't really
I don't think that there's an issue if
somebody I don't know what they wear in
prison I've never been there so
I don't know if the outer clothing to me
if that is used that to me is not a
problem that's not inhumane that's
normal I people give me clothes all the
time
the prop the problem that's becomes just
not acceptable is giving somebody
somebody else is used
so would that be a separate line keeping
this one adding the unstained unstained
and sanitized and then adding another
line for undergarments any undergarments
that are impacted
I mean if you
if you'd Mark right still be there I
don't think that that necessarily is if
you think so just take it out all
together or sheets that's what it would
cover the sheets right and undergarments
you could make it a little separate line
but any items provided by the county or
you could just say and I feel like I
think it's still appropriate for
clothing as well because I don't think
an inmate would necessarily want a blood
stain from somebody else on there I mean
I could imagine
problems socially speaking amongst
inmates if one person has a blood stain
um so unstained I think is adequate for
clothing
but uh explain to us what happens
laundry right now the laundry policy is
it's the same for any inmate uh it's
gets washed regularly and they're
provided with female undergarments
I don't know if they're new or if that
and that's just for Rockingham County I
would have to check with all 10 to make
sure that everybody has the same policy
sometimes policy slightly vary from here
to there but I'm happy to shoot out an
email real quick and see if I can get an
answer on that while we're sitting here
if a if a person
generally speaking if a person needed
something new are they have you seen
where they're giving something that that
may still have a visible stain on it say
like a pair of of jeans or I don't know
what I don't know what you wear in
prison I
uh I don't know the answer off the top
of my head but I'm happy to try and find
out representative Rhodes okay
um so if and there's a difference too I
think between what you're issued
initially and from what I understand
from all the testimony we heard both in
the county and the state what happens is
you are in are issued specific clothing
for you when laundry day comes that
clothing is bagged in a bag for you and
you get these same exact items back to
you and so there's a difference between
getting somebody else's stained and then
your own that's been laundered but you
know because I know I have stained
underwear so okay so then what so that's
the word thing I never thought I would
say that in recording
own back
then that's not necessarily so gross so
I would say shall initially be Pro so
undergarments specifically shall
initially be provided new
um and and then we can say returned
sanitized to the to the to the original
owner so is it more like it's an issue
of the original well more like it's an
issue of the original
um being issued it right we want to make
sure they're not being issued recycled
underwear is the main thing so saying
that undergarments shall be issued new
okay so hold on one second she's been
trying to say
did you have a question for me first I'm
just I'm thinking sorry the link the
English teacher in me is thinking the
language so upon
um arrival at the incarceration facility
shall be issued new underwear yeah you
could say something like upon arrival or
upon intake I think either of those
would be appropriate
and then with ours
um we we do issue new underwear upon
arrival we also allow for the
opportunity to get a additional pairs
every six months I I don't know that we
need to dive that far into it but that's
kind of what how we handle things and
then as far as laundry
also with the laundry everything that an
inmate owns is labeled so not just the
bag but I don't know how it's done in
the counties
um yes everybody has their name in every
piece of clothing that they have so
that's another way that we we keep it
separate but I would imagine the county
is also label I will say for the record
if I apologize
will you I I
find it okay I thought she was asking
you I will say that since I don't think
we had
um the representative from the counties
at the hearing for the record the people
who had the complaints about infections
and things were not from Rockingham
County
thank you representative do you
understand that and I apologize to the
company for not being here but it was
the beginning of the session I didn't
mean to call you out I was just saying
in case like the Rockingham County
Commissioner was like no it wasn't
Rockingham that was the problem
all right so what I'm hearing is the the
clothing
foreign sorry I'm vertically challenged
and I can't ever reach my microphone so
the clothing is is
labeled just like it is in a nursing
home it's labeled when it goes off the
laundry and then that bag is also
labeled
so getting it back to that particular
person is really not the issue
it's not an issue in our facility okay
representative thank you in the counties
is it she's not sure she's look she's
frantically looking on she's frantically
looking into it what I currently have is
that upon intake undergarments uh shall
be provided in new condition and then
any other any any product let me see
what the wording was what line are you
on so that was the line that we created
um I would say we would add it yeah 19
and 20. so specifically adding a
statement on its own that's saying upon
intake undergarments shall be provided
new probably before the word or maybe at
the end of the paragraph but then the
other sentence is any items provided by
the county to incarcerate persons shall
be provided an accurate adequate number
unstained and sanitized so that would
cover also underwear
but I'm just saying that they have to
sanitize those panties it's been
assigned to you new but if you do stain
them then then it has to be sanitized
before they they give it back to you or
if it's stained stained permanently then
they'll replace it that'll that all
makes
that all makes sense I think I think
we're getting this wording and again I
really don't mean to be ridiculous about
but I'm telling you last year some of
the things these people came up with I
was like what it's understandable where
do you live like how do you come up with
this stuff you know so now I don't want
to come back over two words
representative Selleck has a so would we
add that line to both
um the county and the state
yes okay
okay we're going to duplicate it for
both the state and the county
and procedurally so it'll be between
line ninth it'll be between lines 19 and
20 is where we're going to add that and
then the word unstained will be after so
it says and in inadequate
number unstained and sanitized before
being provided did you have something I
have an answer on the laundry
so uh each facility each shell is
different it depends upon if they use
laundry bags but for the most part
they're mainly sharing clothing uh it's
all washed dried and they get fresh
clothes as a clothing exchange they have
inmates come in and get clean use
clothes they uh superintendent Henry did
want me to mention that they could never
afford new clothes for inmates every
single time
but if they're damaged or something like
that that's a that's a different
situation well I think that's what we're
what we're going for
what were you going to say I'm just
building on what she just said that I
think that's what we're going for is
that if it's stained then we're
providing new we're taking out of
circulation but if it's you know if it's
clean there's no stain it's been
sanitized it's ready to go
yeah I was just gonna so I was thinking
that regardless if it was still stained
if it was cleaned and sanitized for the
same person it would be reused for the
same person it would be taken out of
circulation after that person leaves for
someone who's coming in new aside from
undergarments which would be it sounds
like what we just heard is not every
County duplicates the state process of
making sure those particular items
always go back to the same incarcerated
person so
I don't know if the counties are willing
to duplicate the state process and have
those items always be returned to the
individual they will if we pass the RSA
it's well well true I am a big advocate
of the fact that we are the ones that
write the policy they have to follow it
okay so basically we're on the same page
here that
if it's yours originally and it comes
back to you
then that is okay what we don't want is
this has you know some some stained
residue on it which is clean and
sanitized
right but going to
somebody different right
um so superintendent I just asked the
question uh whether or not it's new
underwear or not and superintendent
Henry said no it's washed and cleaned if
it's ripped or Stained it's
automatically disposed of
so we're codifying what some counties
are doing that sounds fine
but he's still saying it's not new Under
so they we're saying they have to be
issued new when they're brought in and
and he's he's fine with that change to
new I did ask him that okay I'm glad can
I just like off topic say how happy I am
that this subcommittee is entirely women
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
no I don't I think the chair was
probably made a wise decision in that
case
he goes
about time wondering if when if we need
to give a floor speech on this if we'll
need to bring in show and please God no
[Laughter]
yes
this will be a 20-0 on consent that's
that's what I love
you I will say just for anyone new that
our house rules do state we're not
allowed to bring props
to the floor I'm just saying we could
you could wear it if it's you know you
fashion into like a brooch or something
a scarf
on consent I like it your job
one little thing that had been
irritating me in the back of my head
that I never put into the language is
and this would be probably
line
uh earlier in
[Laughter]
he's like I'm just here
I'm just
everything's a teachable moment what
happened did I miss something or did I
say something
oh okay yes he's like the how what shade
of crimson has he turned
um so
I I want to add when menstrual products
are provided that they provided be
provided in a timely manner because some
of the stories I was personally told was
that maybe there was a delay between
when they would ask and when it would
get approved so I I don't know if this
subcommittee would be okay with the
words in a timely manner so I think
we're back I so I think we're back to
that's a probably a judgment what does
timely manner mean to one person and
another is that indeed does that have to
be I mean how do you identify timely
manner it's the kind of thing that would
go to court and be right so I don't know
if we I don't know if that is something
that that can be
regulated how would you guys within
determine a number of hours
have it like that
spelled out in our policy unfortunately
it's not it's kind of not really a
second thought it's just provided the
same way we would provide toilet paper
or and I know that like our mail
Corrections Officers that have the belts
they carry tampons in there just in case
somebody needs one so it's I mean it's
not really a availability issue there so
you know when you're in the hospital
and so as an example I'm there for four
days I rep I wrecked my snowmobile and I
broke both sides of my pelvis and my
shoulder and they would say you know you
have to push the magic button to ask for
the magic pill in you know half an hour
later whoa now I'm dying right and
that's a lot of pain that's yeah so but
to them they had to put in the order
they had to get it right so then I was
like all right well I'll ask for it a
half an hour ahead of time so that it's
there in that half an hour nope you
can't do that because you know by the
timing so to them that was a timely
manner to me it wasn't very efficient
wouldn't may I ask the representatives
from the prison in jails um if an hour
would be reasonable can we put a time in
there
caution you against putting a time
putting them in a specific time just
because something is always going to
happen
I mean we don't make that time what does
that mean and if you say like well I got
it to them in three days then yeah see
that's not really reasonable is it so
what would what do we do do you have a
suggestion
that I think the function of reasonable
in the law isn't to guide the person
implementing it it's really to initiate
a discussion during litigation
and so the concern over setting a time
limit is over litigation it's kind of
neither here nor there because if when
you get to the point of debating what
reasonable was you're in litigation so
maybe the sort of Middle Ground would be
to say within an hour unless
circumstances require
um something along those lines barring
extenuating circumstances
so I I agree with you I'm not trying to
make it have to be necessarily a lawsuit
I'm just trying to
well we want I think it's a judgment of
what reasonable is to some people I mean
reasonable is
in the point of adding even if it's that
squishy term of reasonable the point of
adding it is so that if there is a
county that has been grossly negligent
and has caused someone to wait for days
they have that to go to in the RSA they
can then make a case to a judge and say
this wasn't reasonable three days is not
reasonable for a menstrual product
um so it there's I think we need to have
something addressing time in there I
just it's how how specific the
subcommittee wants to get I'm happy to
be as squishy or specific as you all
like
What were what
what do you guys have in yours is this
is this a problem that we actually do we
have to make sure we put in here
I would say we don't have a problem
like in general we haven't needed to put
that into our policy because we haven't
had that problem at the president with
with somebody not getting it and what
they consider to be a timely manner but
I I defer I mean so if we put it in
there you guys are already doing it
anyway so it's it's kind of right it's
happening anyway I think saying
something like an hour is very specific
so I I would be I would be concerned
with an hour
um but two hours I don't think we should
put a time frame what were you going to
say represent I was just going to say
um on that line between 11 and 13. you
we could say something about you know
superintendent blah blah blah she'll
provide the products to all people who
went straight in the custody of the
county an adequate Amounts is necessary
at no cost to such person
um and uh in a timely manner and no and
um something about intermediency and uh
and uh meeting the immediacy needs of
the inmate or something so nobody's
waiting and to address the urgency or
something I'm just in such a way
that it's an immediate need you can't
wait necessarily immediate needs yeah
yeah that's not a time thing but
no no no
well if you mean grammar yes but if you
mean intense no
so is there a
grammatical
I just think the immediacy it doesn't
give a specific hour or whatever but
it's certainly prescribes that there's
an expectation that people should not
have to wait for something that is an
immediate need and and I like that I
like that terminology it's sort of a we
know when you need it you need it
and then I like that all right so I have
you guys got that written down you got
that written down over there in such a
way as to meet any immediate need
I like that it's just immediately sense
of urgency hurry up yeah
I have it are you up on an amusement
park
will what who sends all this to get
revised I'm happy to volunteer my
services but anybody
can do it so this is what this is what
will happen
um
I would say that representative Reed's
making all these notes because you know
this is kind of her her little project
so she will take it and have it amended
again and then she'll give it back to
she'll send it back to the committee and
then when we actually do the executive
session on this
somebody will will say that they want to
make a motion about to pass this
legislation and they offer Amendment
whatever this amendment number is and
then we'll discuss that Amendment and
then we'll first vote for the amendment
and then after that we'll vote to pass
it as amended
so
um all right but for this for today what
are we going to do here
um
so the amendment number is going to
completely change yes yes right like
multiple Madam chair all right so this
so this little paper I have is kind of
irrelevant right now because of the
amendment number that we have is going
to be a different amendment number
so the the changes I have just to recap
um at on line 13 after the words at no
cost to such person I have uh and in
such a way that meets any immediate
needs on line 14 I have after the words
provided a choice of insert standard
issue feminine hygiene products
and then the lines 19 and 20 we are
saying any items provided by the county
and this will be duplicated to the state
as well
all this language I'm saying uh to
incarcerate persons that are impacted by
Administration shall be provided in an
adequate number unstained and sanitized
before being provided and that upon
intake undergarments shall be provided
in a new condition
mm-hmm
and those are the changes that I have
where where are you putting the upon
intake are you putting at the end of
this sentence
so after 21 after that line 21 at the
end of that paragraph before section the
second paragraph
new section
so
okay
my thought would be
on line 19 where it says menstruation
period see that yes
if we put
the first part about upon intake first
okay because that's kind of comes the
logical sequence yeah okay yeah so if we
put that line first about upon intake
whatever that wording is and then after
that any items provided that are been
with you yeah does that make sense it
does make sense I don't care I feel like
we're going backwards if we do it the
other way no I don't I would actually
stay awake at night I appreciate the on
that the Nuance there I do welcome to my
world
awesome all right well ladies do you
have anything that we did not address or
that we need to change or anything input
I don't think so I appreciate the
opportunity to speak did we beat this
dead horse
I think so
but a room full of women came to a
consensus about language and I love it
I'm here for it I would just ask that uh
representative Reed shared the final
Amendment with me so I can run it not
all 10 counties obviously host females
just so I can run it past those
superintendents because I need your
email address yes uh superintendent
Henry is obviously only one of ten so
and I would appreciate both your email
addresses and I will make sure if you
want all subcommittee members if you
want I can include all of you as
co-sponsors on the amendment so that
everybody's name is on it
I'm happy
all right representative
thank you for your work on
good
you good I'm good thank you are you good
I'm good all right I will close the
work session on House Bill 421 thank you
thank you 40 minutes good job